Creating images that are
more than good enough
is what this case
study is about.
This happened quite a
while ago, about-- I can't
believe it's 20 years ago.
In this lab, this is the image
that the researchers came up
with on their own.
You're seeing a surface that has
etched-out hydrophobic lines.
And so when you drop
water on the surface,
the water stops at
these hydrophobic lines.
This measures across
about 4 millimeters.
So these are drops
of water that are
taking on the shape of
the hydrophobic lines.
And this is how it was used in
the article that was accepted.
I luckily came across
it, because this sort of
started my whole career 20
years ago in science imaging.
What I did with this image,
as you've seen before,
is I asked them to please make
a triangle so I could start
working a little bit with this.
And I dropped some water on
that triangle, also etched out.
Here, as you remember,
I made the picture
with direct lighting.
Here I diffused the lighting.
And I was playing
around a little more.
Another chip was
etched out as well,
and I started using fluorescing
material to drop on the chip.
This gold, it's called a
self-assembled monolayer.
In this image, I wanted
to show a sense of scale,
so I used the
syringe with which I
dropped the water
on the surface,
just to give you
a sense of scale.
Finally, getting around to
submitting for a cover design,
I asked the researchers,
could you please
at least give me a grid
of the etched lines
so I could then drop onto the
grid fluorescing green water
and fluorescing blue water?
And you could actually
see the etched marks
creating the hydrophobic lines.
I didn't like
seeing it too much.
Those lines were in the way,
so just moving the camera ever
so slightly gave
me a cleaner image.
And again, I was imagining
the journal's logo at the top.
What was really important
was that the editors
felt that the way I photographed
it was misinformational.
That is, you're seeing two tones
of green and two tones of blue,
and that was
miscommunication for them.
It turns out that's
really the way it was.
But in the end,
what we did decide
to do was give them
a simplified version,
where I focused in tightly
onto the square drops of water,
as we call them. (They're
colored water with fluorescing
dyes.) Each square is
about 4 millimeters across.
And it was a simplified
image, as what we strive for.
And in the end, we were lucky,
and it did get the cover.